[Music]
and another skype edition
I'm a very special guest man and we just
recently found out that we are fans of
each other and if it wasn't for a random
fan on Twitter we probably never would
have known and I appreciate you joining
man we got David Pakman on the show he's
hosted the David Pakman show has a huge
following online and YouTube and other
various outlets man so I appreciate you
taking out the time to join us man thank
you no it's awesome to be with you for
sure man for sure man um yeah so as I
stated man I'm a big fan I was I was
subscribed to your YouTube channel for a
while now and a Twitter fan reached out
I guess you you're you're kind of doing
random podcasts or you asked your
Twitter friends whose podcast should I
jumped off jump on and one of your
friends said might and you were like I'd
love to and that's how that's how we
kicked off and and so I have a whole
bunch of questions a whole bunch of
things I want to get into man but I kind
of want to dig into who you are as a
person before we get into everything
that you subscribe to and and and what
the things you believe but how did you
start becoming getting getting into
politics and then the the transition to
[Music]
like radio and online media like how did
that whole transition start because I've
always been interested in that journey I
grew up in politics and in my family was
always super political so I was always
interested in politics but in college I
started interning at a radio station and
doing my own thing building a show
seeing classmates end up in jobs they
didn't really like and I figured I would
try to do this show as long as possible
and see if I could turn it into a
business and a way to earn a living so
that was like
my motivation to keep pushing the show I
was always into the political part of it
it was just sort of natural that I'd be
talking about politics and I went to
grad school straight after undergrad and
again I saw my classmates becoming
bankers and financial advisors and stuff
that I'm sure is great for them but I
didn't want any part of so I just kept
kept going and eventually you know we
got some investors and was able to hire
a team and now it's it's it's my thing
it's my full-time thing yeah it's very
well run there's kind of this growing
the age of the Internet is a special
time it's a funny place to be alive
right now
and there's this growing independent
media out there that's that's that's
it's kind of just just been brewing in
our society and I believe that you have
a very big voice in it especially people
who align with my ideology so well it's
hate categorizing it like this but like
at the left or liberal or whatever the
case may be I don't even know how to
describe it anymore because there's so
many different terms and subsets of
those terms and it just gets messy man
but like there's not a lot of
left-leaning independent media that is
as prominent as the opposition would you
agree with it absolutely and this is a
major problem I mean I've been talking
for a while about how the right is just
super well organized they're super well
funded I mean if you look at I hate to
like promote people that I don't think
are doing good things but just like for
our conversation there's this group
Turning Point USA and they've got this
guy named Charlie Kirk and Candice Owens
is involved with them and it's like they
have a farm team and they fund it and
they train these people and they spit
out of college sometimes they don't even
go to college really well-prepared
well-spoken activists on the right and
they go on to have shows they have a
whole system of funding these shows and
they're just better organized than the
people on the left are it's all there is
to it you know I agree Matt and
the interesting thing is this is is when
you kind of step back in and analyze
that situation politics is not my forte
right and it never was and I didn't get
really into politics until after I
retired from the NFL and then I was
always somewhat aware you know I did I
was I was a history fan growing up but
you know I paid attention in school I
always did my independent research but
it was never like my my shtick but but
coming out of coming out of the NFL when
I when I after I retired I realized that
that the climate in this country was
huge and once you dig into the reasons
why politics is the the core of that and
so when you step back and analyze that
situation you go down your the internet
rabbit hole you're trying to find things
that you really trying to challenge
myself what I did i Cho chunk challenged
myself trying to test my ideologies see
if there's people out there who are
like-minded and that's exactly what I
found but the small pockets of the
things that I believe in aren't being
represented and it's just like you said
the the right seems to brand themselves
way better and it's kind of my I don't
mind rational discourse right at all but
I think the issue is that they're kind
of using it it's it's it's it's it's
kind of indicative of America's cultures
like we love blood like we love it and
so they kind of spew these talking
points and these and these just things
that can't necessarily be verified if
you really dig into it yeah and I was
just talking about this with like a guy
who does talent management for a lot of
people in my space and he was saying
that there's a lot of people who take
these super black and white positions
they take the most extreme position
possible on every issue because it gets
attention but in the long run it's just
like a huge disservice to actually
figuring out the problems of society
because most stuff you
a gray area that's kind of the reality
and if you're able to have more rational
discourse that understands that even if
you're on the left and you think your
position is like 90% of the way there
there often will be some 10% where the
other side maybe is making a point and
this is not me saying that the right
spot is just in the middle of the left
and right often it's not but it's very
profitable to just pick the most extreme
position you can and get as much
attention as possible with it but
everybody loses in the long run when you
do that you know I agree 1,000% and
that's kind of that's kind of what I've
done is of I follow a lot of right-wing
media like a lot of them and I'm row
buys on a daily basis because it's all
its on my feet but I kind of find it
necessary for growth like because every
now and it just like you said there will
be something in there's like you know
what that lends credence to the things
that I that I believe in the things that
I've researched but like you said it's
it's it's kind of um it's kind of
ripping the fabric of and I'm not
necessarily I don't I don't know if it's
a good thing or a bad thing but you said
it's not good for the long run and I'm
unsure because I think it had to come to
a boiling point because like you said it
was it was it was its extremes right its
extremes but it's I think it had to come
to a boiling point because I think this
that that rhetoric has been bubbling for
a while I think in my communities we
felt it for sure right so you hear a lot
of a lot of rhetoric from from them
about the whole police brutality thing
well we've we've had this notion in our
head for years and and we didn't
necessarily have the data to back it up
and I don't think we still do because a
lot of social science is anecdotal and
so you can't really justify some of the
things people are filling with
statistics and I think that's that's a
huge sword that they like to poke into
people as well but social science just
isn't isn't isn't regular science so as
you're as you're um as you're as you're
navigating your way through this
shark-infested pools of politics man
what's what's what's
one of the things that you've I can I
guess because they like learn from the
other side cuz III don't I don't I don't
think that everybody's evil minutes but
I do think there are provocateurs but
I've learned a lot from the other side
as well I mean I this is like kind of
not a great thing to learn I wish it
wasn't something I'd learned but the
facts ultimately don't matter I mean
that's it's it's a disappointment
and you're kind of alluding to that also
the facts really don't matter because
most political decisions are being made
based on kind of like the way the wind
is blowing in public opinion and what
determines that is can you make people
afraid of stuff fear is like an awesome
motivator to get people to go and vote
in a particular way or to donate to a
particular cause and can you make an
argument that sounds good in like 15
seconds right and this is the problem
for a lot of the left that like I often
use the example of taxes where like the
right has this awesome position in that
it's simple which is it's my money taxes
it's my money I should just keep as much
of that as possible lower taxes are good
it's like so concise and simple and
perfect it's not realistic in any way
and then you go to the left and it's not
like the left has the opposite where
they go we want the highest tax as
possible no it's like the left says well
yeah everybody wants to keep as much of
the money they've earned but we live in
society and if you want roads and police
and fire you have to find some amount of
you've lost right like I've already
bored so that is one of those things
where once you understand that and there
are people on the Left who get that and
are trying to frame issues and in a more
appealing way it sucks that it's
basically what can you make shiny and
attractive rather than can you have
really substantive discussions and
figure out complicated stuff but the
right is just excellent at it it's kind
of like a that's shitty because it's
kind of like a lose-lose because it's
like what what they sell is like you
said it's more
sexy so like fear fear always sells
blood always sells and that's and that's
and that's a lot of their their their
talking points you don't a point that I
love to talk with people about man which
is which is taxes in this whole it's a
huge and it's so intricate it's a huge
debate in our country and it's a lot of
the right talking points right now is no
socialism socialism communism Marxism
versus democratic socialism if you could
break down those terms a little bit just
for my viewers who are a hundred percent
of where I don't want to have a little
bit of a conversation about that okay so
there's a huge confusion right now and
there's a lot of straw Manning going on
and we can talk about what that means
also so basically if you're taught
Marxism is a specific type of socialism
communism that was espoused by Karl Marx
when people talk about communism there
they're usually referring to like
Stalinism and Leninism in early
twentieth century Soviet Russia that's
where the government owns the means of
production so like instead of you know
me owning my business socialism would be
all of my employees share ownership and
communism would be the government owns
it and tells the people who works at
that business right so these are like
different different versions and the
problem that we're seeing right now is
that a lot of stuff that's not any of
these things that's just kind of like
Norwegian social democracy are being
called socialism by the right so like an
example would be socialized health care
people here socialized and they say well
that must be socialism but when you look
at Norway and Sweden and Denmark where I
just was these are these are capitalist
economies but they've figured out that
everybody's better off when you don't
have to pay for health care the way we
do in the United States
so they've socialized just that element
of society but it's still capitalism
people can still have their own
businesses you can still make profit and
what the right has kind of successfully
done is mess with the terms where they
will start talking about how bad
socialism or communism or Marxism are
which are perfectly fine debates to have
but there's really no big clamoring in
the united states to become an actual
socialist nation or a communist nation
we're basically talking about like
Scandinavian style reforms education
health and health care that type of
thing and this what I don't understand
about like their position on it is that
they don't necessarily view the police
or military or roads or anything as
socialist institutions or socialized
institutions depends who you talk to I
mean so sorry for having you still man
there there I mean so like okay if you
are like an extreme libertarian you
might make the case that the government
shouldn't even be providing police and
that roads should be built by private
citizens who then can charge people to
use those roads and you know if the
market allows you to charge a certain
amount for people to use your road then
that's great and if nobody uses the road
you'll lower your price right they have
this like idea of like a fruit Odle free
market libertarian situation which is
completely unrealistic I think most of
the right is not making those extreme
arguments not to defend them not to
steal me on them as you're saying but I
think most of the right is just wanting
health care and education to remain in
the for-profit sector and in order to do
that they are pretending as though
Danish health care is socialist when
it's not understand is why are we always
putting ideas in juxtaposition with past
civilizations you know like I don't I
think that's a lot of false equivalency
going on because you have things that
nobody had in the past like the internet
that is a huge differentiating factor in
my in my humble opinion does that ever
but I mean I can't wrap my mind around
why
was comparing to past civilizations it's
because it's politically clever to do it
because if you can convince people that
Danish or Swedish style healthcare is
bad because Stalin killed millions of
people in Russia you can get people to
say I don't want Swedish style health
care even it though they don't have
anything to do with each other right so
it's like it's a political calculation
and unfortunately it works because a lot
of people don't understand the
historical references and I think this
is my problem with politics in general
is I think I don't hold on but I think
it was Socrates and he was and they was
talking about democracy and how the fall
kind of democracy would be if you have a
whole people putting people in power or
voting on issues that are not informed
enough to do so it's gonna be it's gonna
be chaos which i think is what's going
on now it's like you can go to Bernice
and off I'm gonna say Bernie Bernie
Bernie Sanders rally sorry you can put
her says rally Trump rally or whatever
the case right or left both extremes and
you're gonna find people in the crowd
that you randomly interview and you
gonna have some stupid people that
you're gonna interview like it's just
the case yeah okay so I agree with you
that you can if you've got a rally with
a thousand people you can find people
who don't know anything no matter what
the rallies for and you can make them
look really bad the only thing I would
disagree with you about is that I don't
know what extreme ideas Bernie's
presenting at the rally I'm sure you can
find people at the rallies who have some
extreme ideas but most of Bernie's ideas
are like totally mainstream in northern
Europe right no no I wasn't saying his
ideas I'm just saying okay extreme far
extreme I'm saying she's just left and
right just obviously that's a spectrum
and and like the like you'll see people
like you said that this just are
uninformed and I think that's that's the
issue now is there's so much
misinformation and it's why I'm grateful
for people like yourself who are who are
honest in their reporting and honest and
their delivery of their message because
I really think you're you try to be
objective I don't think you try to do a
lot of clickbait I don't think you try
to do anything
dishonest I think you try to really give
people an honest calculation of the
events as you see it and exactly yeah
it's what I call I just I comment in
good faith so like you can disagree with
my conclusions or you could tell me my
priorities are wrong or you can tell me
that I just don't understand an issue
but I'm not deliberately distorting the
facts on which I base my opinion like
week let's debate whether I'm coming to
the right conclusions or not but I'm not
arguing in bad faith which unfortunately
a lot of people do because in a way they
have no choice if you're defending the
indefensible you kind of have no choice
but to argue in bad faith yeah yeah and
that's that's one of one of the I think
my big if anybody wants to kind of
present themselves as a as a rational
thinker one of one of your tools is
exactly that just being honest with
yourself and not and not and doing your
best not to live inside of the echo
chamber that you create cuz nobody
there's there's there's nobody mandating
you follow anybody or anything that you
follow like so you have to you have to
cognizant least seek out things that you
disagree with and see if it still fits
your narrative or or your if you're
comfortable in that worldview one of the
best things you can do is just say okay
here's my opinion about this issue what
is the best argument against it what's
the best possible argument not that I
believe it but like what what argument
could someone come up with that would be
the most dangerous to what I now believe
and then figure out if you can argue
against that best position so like I
recently did a death penalty debate and
to prepare I went through and with death
penalty like I'm pretty familiar with
with most of the arguments in favor of
it I'm against it what are the best
arguments someone can make for the death
penalty it deters crime it's fair it's
in the interests of society cost argue
you know whatever go through them and
then figure out well how would I argue
against those arguments and if I can't
maybe there
arguments I didn't I didn't find that by
the way but but that that's like the
best way I think to examine your own
beliefs not as beautiful I love to hang
out with men so next time I Boston man
I'm gonna take you to dinner because I
it's a serious thing it's a serious
thing in that you have a responsibility
to be an informed citizen and you having
some kind of self checking process is
imperative because you'll just fall
victim to your own bias and it's I see
it all the time and and what's what's
worse is you know I follow all these
right-leaning
outlets and it's it's more like in
performance than anything else now and
then I and then I'll get with people
that I know who are a little bit right
of what I believe and they're just
spinning out talking points rather than
like trying to really have a
conversation and that [ __ ] is
frustrating in his head I'm like I know
exactly where you got that from right
yeah yeah and this also I mean this
isn't a hundred percent related to this
but you talked about the responsibility
that exists there I like to always make
the point that people who say I'm just
kind of like not into politics and I
don't vote I don't get involved that's a
decision and it's not a neutral decision
because when only half of the population
votes the non voters are a huge factor
in who ends up making decisions for you
right like we have a hundred senators
and it's not just the people who vote
that decide who those hundred senators
are everybody who chooses not to vote is
making a decision that's not a neutral
decision and so if you aren't pleased
with how society is organized right now
and your solution or your decision is
not to vote you're actually part of how
we got to where we are I would agree
with you my former self would not agree
with you but I agree with you now so
like so you used to have that same idea
that like I used to I used to have
almost a conspiracy theory idea where
it's like they they put people they they
picked the president before years and it
like I was that's that's how far I've
come
that's very interesting yeah I used to
be really
like conspiracy theory doubt yeah I'm
glad I'm what what like how did you get
out of that because a lot of
conspiracies hit there as I talked to
you it's like they're in a circle so
there's like no way out where evidence
for their conspiracy reinforces it but
then lack of evidence is part of the
conspiracy so like it's like a room with
no door you know no it's a great way of
framing it because it's exactly right I
don't think I was ever uh I don't I
don't think I was ever really ready to
die on any Hill right I was I've always
been open-minded and I think that's the
kind of the doorway for conspiracy
theories is you're open minded right you
kind of like for the most part but but
for me it was and so it I didn't I don't
really understand or or care to
understand how to validate the
information that was coming in so a lot
of the things that I thought I knew was
kind of just hearsay and what got me out
of it was my interest in science and I
started I started really falling in love
it was really gravity gravity was the
thing that got me interested in science
I saw a documentary on Einstein and I
was like this [ __ ] is so interesting
besides I dove in really deep on like
what gravity was and I special
relativity general relativity and then
that that led me into other sciences and
and just the the methodology of how we
prove things to be true to it to the
degree that we can as human beings and
once I really understand also I was a
philosophy major so I was I was I was
always an outward thinker like how far
I'll kind of go but bringing it all back
I think it was just at the end of the
day how things are the how true are the
things that we say to be true and that
that I lost sleep because of that I
didn't understand so I I after after a
while it just it made me really question
every single position in my life and I
think to be a well-rounded human being
to be a kind human mean to be a
compassionate human being I I have to
find reasons why I have to know why I'm
doing what I'm doing and why I'm
thinking the way I'm thinking I'm really
interested in this
called life and to bring her back all
around like that's that's basically what
drew me back in was this like when you
were in the NFL and you were into some
of this stuff what were you like were
you an outlier and that these were the
things you were thinking about and
looking at yeah I think my religious
ideologies definitely there's not many
atheists in in the NFL oh is that true
yeah not that is not many huh I think
I've only seen like a couple actually
for some reason football is extremely
indoctrinated in religion especially
Christianity it's just like I know that
our Father player by heart because since
I was a kid we said it before every game
and I just didn't think anything of it
but it's just it's extremely inundated
with religion I'm not sure what I think
it was because it came from the south
and so that Southern culture kind of
cultivated that that mindset but yeah
not interesting you know it really is it
really is I what I wanted to do like a
short like lo docu-series on it not just
football but just sports in general how
it's how it's super it's inter woven
with religion it is I mean from the
outside it sort of does seem like the
NBA is probably like the more
progressive of the major sports leagues
as far as the players in the
organization but I don't know if that's
accurate like football and baseball
always seem way more like status quo
good old boys you know yes I think it is
I think I think the reason is because
the NBA there for a while they they
didn't have the best viewership it was
when the Commissioner at the time put
direct like dress codes for the players
or stuff like that yeah but there was a
shift in in management and where they
realizes what needs to happen in the NFL
but there was a shift in management
where they realized that the players are
the league it's not this it's not this
year like the NFL loves the brands like
oh the shoe there's like [ __ ] the shield
I was just telling that when I was in
those meetings or like [ __ ] this year
the players are the league and in
Granite the the league is is its
separate entity but the players make the
league go and they brand their players
and they let their players be
individuals and they
the the overseers of the NBA are more
progressive than the NFL as well though
they they they advocate their players to
be social yeah social about social
issues I mean to be yeah it to be loud
about it and they advocated for sure are
the would you say like in the locker
room if there's political talk it's
mostly right-wingers that are playing in
the NFL or like a lot of non-political
people no I would say it's more left
than than not but here's I would be
disrespectful but I I wasn't into
politics when I was playing super like
it was like I really got into it
probably I was like 25 26 is when I
really started paying attention for real
yeah and then but even then it was
loosely so I was I was spitting out
talking points and left-leaning talking
points without understanding the the
real issues and so I think that's the
that's the issue in the NFL or the NBA
is you have an expertise and your
expertise is your sport and it takes up
a lot of your time
and a lot of your energy and so I don't
think that there is enough time in your
day to to be somebody like you who knows
oh I
you can sit here have a health care
debate and know all the ends are now and
spit out policies that Obama wrote and
Trump running and you can you know you
know points in it and you can say
section C say you do all that I don't
think there's enough time for that so
you you kind of just gloss over and in a
line with things that are kind of your
cup of tea gotcha gotcha gotcha I mean
the you I'm interested in the whole idea
of like the team's wanting the players
to be who they are because the players
ultimately are sort of like what sell
the tickets with the entire kneeling for
the anthem thing it every time I have a
debate with the right winger about it I
just actually talked to it I was in LA
and this guy Jesse Lee Petersen
interviewed me about it let you finish
your point but yeah you showed so much
patience I have
I was watching it I was watching it with
my lady and she was like is that why
does that do have any kind of platform I
thought it was a parody I thought it was
like yeah I thought it's
indistinguishable from a parody but the
thing was so you know I've always made
the point that ultimately nobody's doing
anything illegal when they kneel during
the anthem it's not a question of
legality so really it just kind of comes
down to like how do the teams manage
their employees and do they want to put
a rule in a handbook which says here's
what you have to do during the anthem or
they just say nothing about it type of
thing so it seems to me that the number
one factor in terms of how the teams
manage it would just be how is it going
to influence ticket sales right like
isn't that what they care about most or
is there something you don't see from
the outside that's like more than that
I said heavy question I think it's a
little bit of both
definitely ticket sales I don't think
this is a ticket size I think viewership
is more important than taking sales to
them audience I guess yeah so so yes but
here was the interesting thing about and
I asked you a question but here's the
interesting thing about that protest to
me because I was a player that that
partook in it when it first happened on
9/11 got death threats all of that but
here's the interesting thing since Colin
got blackballed from the league
allegedly
I toured yes but since he got
blackballed from the league you have a
lot of black folks who are like I'm not
watching and it fell anymore right and
then the opposite is those NFL players
aren't aren't respecting America I'm not
watching so you have both sides
boycotting a league saying they're
boycotting the league over the exact
same issues I found that ironically
hilarious and I have no idea I don't I
don't understand either side honestly I
really don't understand either side but
to answer your question it's really
weird I don't but any chance your
question I think that the ownership in
the NFL is is what's really the
management so like Roger Goodell the
people who
are overseeing and making all these
decisions they're really bad with being
proactive about things so they're
extremely good at being reacted to
things even when the whole domestic
violence issue was a big issue in the
NFL right they're just really bad at
getting ahead of it because they're just
so scared to look like people have flaws
and people have issues like they're just
I don't I don't understand that when
domestic violence is an issue that
doesn't just affect NFL players it
affects police officers military lawyers
doctors it is a huge problem in this
country and you had an ample opportunity
to be the forefront of that conversation
to usher that conversation and that's
the beautiful thing about sports or any
kind of platform is you can bring
awareness to these situations and have
real conversations which is what Colin
initiated but I think that when Colin
did what he did and we all we all joined
them I think they had no idea the
ramifications that could have came from
it and they were trying to clean up as
best they could and they had no idea on
top of that I do believe that the
majority of ownership in the NFL is
extremely right-wing leaning and that's
I mean that's exactly how the culture in
the NFL is is kind of played out
right it's it's not analogous to slavery
but it's it's it's it is in a sense it's
like you just do what you're told and
shut the [ __ ] up like that's how they
view us they don't view us like the NBA
views their players where it's like this
is a partnership like LeBron James can
get it on the phone and call Adam I
think it's silver yeah anytime he wants
whatever the case like I couldn't I
couldn't get Roger Goodell on an email I
tried to track this dude down when the
whole Ray Rice situation happened
because I had a look I had something I
wanted to save him because I I grew a
bit of domestically violent household
and I was like yo this is an important
topic we should we should explore this I
was trying to get hit on my email I was
trying to get I called the office and
they were I got a call back and like
what exactly do you need to talk to him
about my kid get him on the [ __ ]
phone
not the president it was insane but wow
I just think that's how that's just how
they they don't view players of any kind
of value I think they just view them
like cattle honestly like a commodity
almost it sounds like yeah so there's
like what I mean is it about like 1200
NFL players total I'm trying to do some
quick math 53 on a roster at any given
time with 8 practice squad players so 61
times 32 I'm not doing that yeah so
there's like 1,800 players like in the
ecosystem so to speak so it's not like
everybody's constantly trying to talk to
Roger Goodell I would guess it's a
little surprising that it would be that
difficult to just get on the phone with
him you know I mean I was surprised just
like I think it was more ridiculous than
anything else yeah because I was I want
a picture for him I just want to talk to
you about an issue I'm not trying to get
his autograph yeah but uh make kind of
double him back to what we were talking
about I've heard both sides of this this
issue I don't want to get your take on
it do you think that Donald Trump was
good for America and not by any kind of
policy standards and not by any kind of
ideology stance but this is this is why
I kind of make the argument I think it
was okay because he got so many people
involved in politics that wouldn't
necessarily get involved in politics and
now it's kind of riled up dormant voters
in my opinion okay so if there is one
argument that could be made about how in
some kind of like long term time horizon
Trump will be positive for America it
would be that that would be the one
argument which is like two days after
the guy was elected you had marches you
had hundreds of thousands of people etc
the thing is we're not going to know
that for a while because like we haven't
even had our first election since he was
elected so in a couple weeks we'll have
that we'll have midterms if it's there
seems to be record turnout in some of
these
races and people in midterms vote even
less than in presidential elections so
like it is it's possible that he will
inspire so much activism that in 20
years we would say it all happened
because Trump was elected and the
country realized the disaster that
opening up that door was to these sort
of like the corseting of the political
discourse and so on and so forth I don't
think we're gonna know that for 10 or 20
years in the short term the the policy
has all been disastrous either way it's
gonna stroke his ego somehow exactly
right either he either he changed
politics in a way that led to kind of
like the alt-right taking over the
country and he can take responsibility
or he was so influential in making the
entire country realize like this is as
far as we go we've gotta like get
involved at this point but he might not
be alive when we actually figure out
which one it is that's true that's true
[Music]
so so what do you think though do you
think he was or he wasn't I'm not sure
good for the country yeah I think that
he was he's so far it's been a disaster
for the country
I mean you you've got anything you can
identify that seems like it's going okay
I would just challenge you to tell me
what it is that Trump did to cause it
right so like in a recent interview I
was asked isn't it great that we have
all these jobs now unemployment slow and
my question would just be well what
exactly did Trump do that we can say
that's because of him you know I don't
know what what the policy argument would
be but the most concerning thing to me
is just these alliances that he's
destroyed with a lot of other countries
that are that are historically our
friends and allies where now we're not
even part of the conversation you know
France and Germany and all these other
countries where normally we're in the
room for these conversations they don't
it's just like Trump's not a factor
anymore and that's not good for the
United States that's what because I
think this is what I realized my
politics lately is it's just so much
every day
and I know it's part of your job so you
have to be on the knowledge so it's I
miss a lot right and I think the average
American does too so when you say when
you say he's kind of ruined some of our
alliances and you mentioned France or
Germany or something like that
is that like inactive to have they put
out any statements or is it kind of like
no no I mean diplomacy everybody but
Trump understands that that's not how
diplomacy work so you don't do stuff
like that but you know he announces he's
pulling out of the Paris climate deal
okay so then we hear he's not even
invited to climate talks I don't
remember if it was in Switzerland or or
where it was why would the United States
not be part of that conversation I mean
we use like 25 percent of the world's
energy even though we only have four
percent of the population we should be
part of that conversation because we're
a huge part of the problem and if we're
going to have a solution we got to be
part of the solution Trump doesn't seem
to even get it he said climate change is
a hoax created by China and so when
we're not even part of these
conversations everybody loses it doesn't
matter if you voted for the guy or not
like I didn't vote for him but I still
lose because the French president and
the German Chancellor realized we don't
even need to talk to Trump about this
issue he just doesn't get it
I'm trying to wait for wet phrases cuz
you hear you hear a lot from people that
say how can Trump be racist he's black
unemployment rate all of these things
and I correct me if I'm wrong but they
just have an extremely narrow view of
the trend in this country that has been
like if you just zoom out and go to the
previous it's been trending that way
am I wrong in that assessment I met
those are the numbers in the graphs I
see yeah so there's a couple different
things I mean like first of all does it
really matter if he's personally racist
or personally anti-semitic or whatever I
mean it's interesting and I guess I kind
of am curious
whether he is maybe and maybe he maybe
he is and but what really matters is
what is the effect of the policy so in
the end you know like with the
anti-semitism issue it's like on the one
hand he uses all these phrases that the
white nationalists seem to love on the
other hand his son-in-law is Jewish
Jared Kushner so like is he personally
anti-semitic I don't think it really
matters it's more a matter of like what
is the policy are hate crimes against
Jews up or down under Trump's presidency
what's he doing about it so like his his
sincerely held beliefs are relevant but
they're not the most important thing
that that's sort of like number one so
then you get into kind of what you're
saying which is if he takes credit for
something that was trending a particular
way anyway is that an accomplishment or
is it not really an accomplishment
so like when unemployment goes down in
general black unemployment goes down
Hispanic unemployment goes down white
unemployment goes down so if you have
people that are living lives like you
said not everybody's following politics
as closely as I probably do they just
see the headlines they don't apply that
much critical thinking to them not
because the people are ignorant but
because they're living their life and
then it gets into their head and they're
like black unemployment is it's down is
low and then you have to say wait a
second unemployment's just down he
hasn't done anything specific to target
that issue and then we've got to think
about like okay so do we vote for him
again because black unemployment down or
is that not really a good reason to go
for him see that's that's that's a huge
kind of like what we're talking about
the beginning right where the right is
kind of branded themselves like this and
a huge way that I see and you see it
with like the the woman you mentioned
Candace Owens
she's she somehow gotten to Kanye West
and yeah there's this wave of
right-leaning thought that says
black people need to get off of the
Democratic plantation like that's the
phrase that she used and they use a
whole lot yep I don't know exactly how
to feel about that right and I'll tell
you why I don't think that and this is
where like a policy expert like you can
can learn me on this and this is what a
huge reason why I do this podcast to
talk to people that I don't necessarily
frequent so I'm not a huge fan of
politicians in general I think a lot I
think it's I think there's a lot of
crooked stuff going on a lot of money
under the table a lot of lies but I
can't pinpoint a whole lot of policies
that directly are because they're not
gonna be written like they were in the
1800s pointing out the race is a minimum
it's gonna be really covert right so the
the the three strikes that that Bill
Clinton passed I think was three strikes
thing that was that was hugely effective
in our communities and I was a
Democratic policy right so I'm I'm
unconvinced that Republicans want to see
especially the the Republicans in power
want to see people of color extremely
fruitful in this country I find it hard
to believe that but as well as the
Democrats so when I hear something
something like that as you get off the
Democratic plantation I'm not a huge
advocate of politicians in general how
as a as in your expertise how do you
decipher that that message okay so I
mean the first thing would be when
Republicans say and and Jesse Lee
Peterson said it the other day to me he
made the argument that that black people
are on a democratic plantation it might
sound like they're saying we want better
for people of color we want them not to
be sort of like captive of the
Democratic Party
because we want what's best for them
right they frame it like this is because
they want good things for a particular
population but it's also extraordinarily
sort of discriminatory in the sense that
arguing that a population as diverse as
black Americans across the country who
live in different social situations
different cultural situations different
economic situations that they would be
so easily controlled by the Democratic
Party as to be tricked in so many
elections to disproportionately
supporting Democrats I mean to give
another example American Jews like I'm I
grew up Jewish I'm not religious but
like culturally I'm Jewish
Jews are very liberal and they
overwhelmingly vote for Democrats in the
United States maybe even to a similar
degree as black Americans like it's very
high it's like around 80% of Jews vote
for Democrats in presidential elections
yeah and this does that mean that in the
same way Democrats are to use an analogy
are do Jews need to get out of the
Democratic concentration camp right like
that's sort of like the same thing right
which is to say that they're in some way
enslaved by the Democratic Party no in
the same way that black Americans have
accurately identified that in total they
are going to be better off if Democratic
policy is in place than Republican
policy American Jews have figured out
that aside from the fact that
Republicans claim to be these big
supporters of Israel most American Jews
live in the United States not in Israel
and they figured out like we prefer
democratic policy that that's what it is
so I think that there's this kind of
like insulting nature of the right
saying we want what's best for black
Americans they need to get off the
plantation the idea that they are so
easily sort of duped by Democrats is
part of the problem the right thinks
that black Americans would be so easily
duped you know I never even
thought of that angle until you said
that is cut it is a slight it is a
slight a that's exactly right it is and
you know I give this example it's one
counter example and obviously it's more
things are more complicated than this
but when prop 8 came up in California
about gay marriage
a lot of black Californians are
religious Christians and in their
churches there is a relatively like
anti-gay view so even though they do
vote for Democrats in general they
didn't vote with Democrats on Prop 8
because they decided that they they were
against gay marriage so if they're
number one sort of like priority was
just doing what Democrats want they
would have voted in favor of gay
marriage on Prop 8 and they didn't so so
clearly they are thinking for themselves
American Jews are thinking for
themselves and it's sort of insulting to
suggest that these groups are just so
easily tricked you know it's more
branding pretty dope actually that you
framed it like that man do you have any
instances of where the opposite is true
as far as Republican policies that
aren't don't necessarily favor
minorities oh yeah I mean of course so
so first I mean number one voter
suppression okay so the left
by-and-large wants to increase voter
turnout the right is almost exclusively
responsible for stricter voter ID laws
limited voting hours a reduction in the
number of polling places and it's done
strategically and what we're seeing in
Georgia right now for example you have a
really great candidate the first major
party black nominee Stacey Abrams who's
who's the Democratic nominee she's
running pretty even with Brian Kemp and
there's been this strategic move to
close down polling places and early
voting locations in disproportionately
black areas like that's
disenfranchisement there's no whatever
policy you want once you get elected
trying to make it so that certain groups
have a harder time voting that that's
that's just disenfranchisement period
Wow you hear these things right and then
but when you when you actually break
them down it's it's it's it's kind of
gross
it is gross sick it is I mean the the
other thing you know with the policy on
the right is a lot of their so they
claim to be against regulation the right
is always about we've got to deregulate
we've got to give businesses freedom to
you know exist in our capitalist system
and make money we don't want to restrict
their ability to make money and
everybody's better off if the
corporation's are able to make a ton of
money well not really because the first
thing that these corporations do when
they're not regulated is they figure out
who can be the bearer of our pollution
for example when we manufacture products
and what you see very quickly is a lot
of plastics and Teflon there's a big
case involving Teflon that that is being
settled right now the runoff and what we
call negative externalities like the
outside bad things that are caused by a
lot of these business practices
disproportionately impact people of
color the impact poor Hispanic areas
they impact poor black areas and that's
a policy that the right ones they say
get out of the way of business well look
at what business does when we get out of
the way so I think when you when you get
down into the details there's definitely
like an overlap between the racial
impact and the economic impact but in
this country because of the history of
the country those things are very linked
and you don't have to look very far to
find examples of it ya know I was always
a proponent of like racism is the cousin
of classism
and people in power have always used
that devil a double-barrel to bury
people in this country and it's yes it's
an issue I want to touch on that and
then jump jump ships really quick
because there's something I want to get
into but
tell me if I'm extremely off in this
thinking I've said this before my
podcast but from from the research that
I've done and and the reading I've done
on like Marxism or socialism in general
I just find a huge ironic point and tell
me if I'm off on this a lot of people
who are proponents of the free-market
and anti socialism or anti Marxism
they're usually extremely religious
people right like Christian or Jewish or
whatever the case might be
I just find it extremely ironic that
when people die they kind of want to
live in a communist state like that
Kevin is exact
it describes almost to a tee what
communism is and it's a hilarious to me
that that's what they aspire to live in
because to me the whole the whole thing
about socialism is like I'm a
multi-millionaire right so I don't mind
paying higher taxes because it it
distributes the wealth and it helps
people who are not in because how much
is it how many cars do I need how many
houses doing eating granite yes I work
for it I deserve every dollar right but
I understand that it takes it takes a
takes a village right like this is how I
grew up but but people who are extremely
religious and I Greta I'm definitely
throwing a veil over everybody in it
it's stereotyping but the majority if
it's honest in this category is is that
the ideology of heaven and communism are
kind of the exact same thing
I guess I'm interested in this I don't
know enough about like specifically how
different religions see heaven to say
for sure like what what is it about how
they do is it that everybody's equal and
there's no such thing as money because
it's heaven and there's one power yeah
that is interesting yeah I mean listen
that's one of many hypocrisy is that
that sort of exists
the other one that's more obvious is
they claim to want to be in a free
market except for when they don't like
they tend to want subsidies for oil
that's not a free market they're you
know we can talk about other examples
but yeah I mean you're identifying that
there is a double standard that exists
when it comes to a lot of these
ideologies and when it kind of gets down
to the rubber meeting the road there's
always exceptions it's like yes we want
deregulation except where regulations
good for us we want a free market except
when we want our industry to be
protected in some way so yeah I mean the
the heaven one is an interesting one I'm
gonna have to think more about that do
you think that like things like
politican are good not really I mean I
said so I participated in Politico last
weekend and it's you know so there's
this movement right now all about like
let's get all of the ideas out on the
table and figure out what makes sense
and what doesn't make sense and have
debate and that's all really great but I
mentioned earlier that debating and bad
faith is not really that useful and it's
not that political leads to debating in
bad faith but it's sort of set up to be
kind of like political disaster porn
they are setting it up to be sort of
like how can we get people whose
personalities are gonna clash with each
other how we can can we get people
yelling and that type of thing I think
that there is good stuff that happened
at politican and and some pretty good
conversations like I was on a panel
about fake news which is which was
pretty good but there's you know are you
solving is anybody coming away from some
of those debates with like a better
understanding of the issues or are they
just kind of coming away with the idea
of like who yelled the loudest or got
the best insults in you know I don't
know I have doubts about it ya know I
think I think it's all about it's a
course like if it's everything but it's
it's kind of individual like I think
it's good if you if you have if you come
in with some kind of humility right so I
watched
I think is Sam cedar and Charlie Kirk
yep and when you just really get down to
the crux of both points you can kind of
see where their substance in weather is
not substance that's just my opinion
but I don't I think it's the crowd's
role I think like the crowds being there
is the stupidest idea in the world well
here's the thing if you just step back
and think about like everybody you know
that's into politics right and I know a
lot of people in my personal life that
are into politics I don't know anybody
who would fly across the country to go
to Politico and I'm not this isn't an
insult like it was great I met you know
I must have taken hundreds of pictures
there and I met a ton of fans of the
show and it's it was great but the point
is by definition people who are going to
book flights and maybe take time off
from work and get a hotel to go see
people engage in these debates many of
which are just like yelling at each
other it caters to extremes and it's not
all extremists that are there but there
were a lot of extremists there and and
those are also not people who are going
to sort of be convinced that maybe their
views are wrong like the way you were
saying about critically analyzing your
own beliefs so by definition it's sort
of like it appeals to people who want to
see like political blood sports or
whatever name you you kind of want to
assign to it I kind of want a jump man
and I don't wanna keep you too long man
let me know if we run it too long but
I've really enjoyed talking to you man
sure yeah you you touched on the Israel
right and this is something that I have
nowhere near an expert in so anytime I
talk to somebody it's it's really just
trying to gain knowledge about it
there's so many different ways to attack
this so I I guess I'll just start with
the issue that's going on this is what
triggered my interest in it was I was
watching Republican debates one year and
Israel came up and it was almost like
this chain reaction of bombs that said I
was like I'm Pro I'm proud more Pro job
and that to me I just raised a red flag
like why the [ __ ] are we so pro-israel
like I said this is not just I know not
a lot about this at all so when I'm
asking this it's purely for my own
interest why is the u.s. in bed in so
much why do we have so much invested in
Israel okay so yeah there's there's a
lot I mean where do we even like dig
into this right so let's see so the
there's let's talk about the right first
a little bit so there's kind of like two
things going on with the right and their
support for Israel one is that there is
this movement on the right it's a pretty
extreme Christian movement which
believes their basic they're waiting for
the second coming of Christ and they
believe that that is going to happen
through their support of Israel so it's
not even about really figuring out the
conflict it's not really about
understanding the history it's they
literally think that their religious
calling to get the second coming of
Christ to happen is through their
support of Israel so you have like all
these evangelical groups that love
supporting Israel I've heard that part
so that's number one number two you have
people on the right who also don't
really care about the conflict but they
see it sort of like our relationship
with Saudi Arabia which is Saudi Arabia
and Israel are two of the countries in
the Middle East with like a higher
degree of stability and we can do arms
deals and we can support the companies
that donate a ton of money to us the
defense contractors and the others and
so kind of like that's their doorway
into supporting Israel
I tend so the problem with talking about
this issue is that you bear basically
cannot get anybody to accept that your
position is sort of like your sincerely
held position like whenever I talk about
this there will be people on the Left
who say David you can't be trusted on
this issue because you're Jewish so
you're biased to which I always would
say can we not trust anybody who's part
of the LGBT community on the issue of
what rights they should have because
they're biased which is it's a very dumb
argument right so it's number one where
I come down on this is that I am very
critical of the current administration
that's running Israel which is the
Netanyahu administration like I'm on the
left and Netanyahu is on the right and I
don't think that he wants peace I think
he benefits sort of like George W Bush
benefit from the global war on terror
Netanyahu benefits from almost being at
some big next invasion so I think that
like right now the people that are in
charge are a disaster and I think that
they need to be voted out immediately
where the left sometimes gets angry with
me is that I don't believe that Israel
is this sort of like unilateral bad
actor who's looking to kill Palestinians
and a pretty like simple analysis would
indicate that there's really no upside
to them to doing that right like number
one they have the weapons where if they
wanted to really kill a lot of
Palestinians they could have they could
have done it they could have killed a
lot more Palestinians and they don't do
that and they could anytime but more
importantly like when one Palestinian
dies left-wing media goes absolutely
nuts criticizing them so like what
exactly is the upside like if it's some
kind of blood thirst they're doing a
pretty poor job because they're not
killing that many people compared to the
number that they could and the PR
benefit is just not there so so I think
that it's one of these situations where
like if you get dropped into it right
now it's sort of like if Martians showed
up if there were Martians and they came
to earth right now
and we try to explain to them like why
race relations are the way they are in
the u.s. they would all be like wait a
second so like you're all Homo sapiens
you're all humans and you all could live
in peace but you're arguing because
there are like certain people that don't
like other people whose skin is a
certain cut like Martians wouldn't
understand racism if they were dropped
in right now but then like if you go
back a couple hundred years you kind of
understand the context of it I think
there's a similar problem in Israel
right now where there's no understanding
how the current status quo is the status
quo and has gone on for so long unless
you go all the way back sort of to the
beginning and people are very
ideologically tied on the issue and it's
it's a pretty toxic minefield to even
talk about it 100%
that's why I've kind of kind of I
haven't done enough due diligence is
because exactly what you said there's
just you don't talk about an emotional
political issue that is that is super
huge and so a basic rundown is and this
is just for me like I said bro Israel
became a state and we back to that state
in that territory where the natives say
that's not your land and and and the
Israelis say it is and and the just is
is is the only justification for it
being their land the Bible okay so if
you there are there are religious people
who will make legal claims to the land
on both sides I don't care about those
claims at all like I'm not religious I
don't think that that's really an
interesting argument because are you
arguing about something you claim God
wrote when I believe people wrote it I
think it's just it's it's a waste of
time so I don't get involved in that at
all but yes there are people who make
legal claims to the land what's
important I think to understand is that
basically all countries on our planet
the only planet we have right now are
created in three ways right either by by
war meaning you you take it over
forcibly and
it part of your part of your country or
make it a country by annexation which
can include like purchase so like when
the United States did the Louisiana
Purchase and by international treaty or
decree in the case of what now is Israel
not the exact current borders and this
is controversial because it relates to
settlements and a lot of other details
that we could get into but the original
borders of Israel were decreed by
international treaty so there are people
who will try to question sort of like
the legitimacy of Israel even being a
country on the basis that that was done
alike a little more recently like it was
about 70 years ago instead of hundreds
of years ago like some other countries I
don't think that is a legitimate
argument because country there layer
there are three ways that countries are
created and Israel was created in one of
those three ways so I don't think that
that's actually the the controversial
part a lot of people also do
misunderstand they imagined that there
was this country Palestine which in 1948
was just turned into Israel that's not
actually the way it was right so you had
the British Mandate of Palestine which
was under the control of England you had
the land at one point sort of
administered by Jordan and in fact you
have part of the old city the Temple
Mount which is still administered in
that way so it's a it's very complicated
and I don't even know that it's it's the
the exact details or what matter but I
think the point is that there's nothing
in particular about the 1948 lines that
are where we should be focusing I think
the focus should be on like on
settlements and the security situation
right now I don't I don't see how you
can reconcile those things I got to me
this seems like an ever-flowing conflict
that she's gonna go on until somebody
does something real stupid I feared the
same thing so if you had a magic wand
that you could wave over how would you
how would you fix it okay so I would do
a two-state solution which means you
basically create two countries you have
Israel
you have Palestine if that's if that's
the the name that's agreed upon as far
as the borders I would go to what are
called the 1967 borders and again you
gotta have to dig into the issue to
figure out exactly like which version of
the borders do you want I would go to
the 67 borders I think that it would be
important so Israel has built built
settlements over the current into what
are called the occupied territories over
the last several decades which I'm
against I recognize that it's gonna be
very unlikely that in an agreement
Israel would agree to give up all of
that land at this point that they've
basically taken and built stuff on so I
think what you need to do there is
whatever amount of land those
settlements are on you've got to trade
something for it and it can't be like a
crappy land right you need to figure out
like okay here are like 20 square miles
that will say are part of Israel going
forward we've got to give like an
equivalent 20 square miles or maybe even
a little more than that to the
Palestinian state and that's gonna have
to be negotiated I think that East
Jerusalem who needs to be part of the
Palestinian state and I think that you
have to figure out a way to end the
blockade which prevents supplies and
things from getting into the Palestinian
territories and I think it's also
important to figure out a way so the
Palestinian territories are separated
right now like they don't they don't
touch you have to figure out some way
for that to be like a contiguous people
need to be able to go between one and
the other in a way that that feels like
it's actually as a country like one
country I don't know exactly how you
would do it but I think that that would
be important also it's just it's just
such a multi-faceted issue I don't even
know if that's fair man no idea to
discern that that uh man it's it's just
something that's like you're fighting
ghosts right like people people who feel
a certain way about it feel it on a
doctrine like you said that was written
by men and the other side feels the
exact same way and it's like when you're
when you're when you're sitting here
fighting each other
those battles like this is no there's
just no way and the other thing is right
now the people in charge on both sides
are not going to fix this and you might
be right that it might never be fixed
until somebody takes some kind of
horrible decisive action but right now
you've got the Netanyahu administration
in Israel which is very right-wing it's
aligned with really extreme religious
elements they're not gonna fix it
they're not going to be parties to real
peace and on the other side you
unfortunately have Hamas which is an
extremist group in control of the Gaza
Strip and they are not good faith actors
and we don't even have to go into all
the details of what they're doing but
these are these are just not the parties
that are gonna fix the problem period
and Jared Kushner is also certainly not
gonna fix the problem it's sad man when
you see when you look at I mean that's
what kind of rap with this man because I
don't take any more of your time but
like that that exact example right there
of of an issue that has been going on
for decades it's extremely emotional and
it's part of your expertise politics is
your expertise this is what you do how
have you kind of guarded yourself from
the emotional backlash that comes from
somebody on the opposition or just in
general like you or your family because
it's a real thing you just kind of get
numb to it I feel like really yeah I
mean I don't know how else you can do it
because every day it's like if you look
on my youtube channel there's a thousand
negative comments so so like I don't
there's really if you if you're gonna
talk about and even like what I just
said to you everything I just said about
how I would see a solution in the
israeli-palestinian conflict looking
there will be people on the right and
the left who will see this and they will
say I'm a shill and an ideologue for
different reasons they won't even agree
about why right like there will be
people on the right who say that I'm way
off on this and people on the Left who
say I'm way off on this what can I do
you know it's like I'm making the best
assessments I can at the time with the
information I have that
really all I can do you know it's a guy
I agree 100% you always if you get in a
room full of people somebody gonna
disagree with you but I think it's it's
especially interesting when your
livelihood is speaking on these issues
you know what I mean so it's like I I'm
very new to politics and it's extremely
interesting to me and and the more I
grow the more I'm gonna understand about
these kind of issues and even some of
the stances I take now I've gotten death
threats over right I'm sure yeah and so
and so somebody who's inundated in the
political culture as you it would just
like if if if you were like my kin I'd
be like yo take care yourself out there
yeah I mean it's and look look at what
happened this week right I mean bombs
sent to George Soros and Barack Obama
and Hillary Clinton and CNN and maybe
even some others that were just learning
about this is real stuff and people
become radicalized in different ways and
it's it's what can you say it's a real
thing so like mostly what I do is I do
music I do this podcast and it's not
necessary politically based but how I
unwind is I turn on people like you and
see what everyone let me just let me
just relax and see what's going on in
the news today break down this issue
yeah yeah they're like how do you do
that Netflix shows playing chess and
running I guess oh yeah where are you on
Lee chess now get it though okay yeah I
play on Lee chess and on chess calm okay
baby well I'm not good though that's the
thing I mean no I appreciate your time
and I know I kept you a long little wild
man but no problem you're surely good at
what you do I think that you're one of
the few people out there in on your side
of politics that that tries to like I
said tried to give honest critique about
the current situations and
trying to grow and think and and I
appreciate it because I'm the word near
as like I said indicated it as you are
but as I'm finding my own way in this
world people like you give hope to
people like me that that rational
discourse can be had and you can go
about this this society in a civil
manner man so I appreciate thank you
know and likewise I've been you know
keeping an eye on on what you're doing
and I think it's great and you've
definitely got you know I what you have
that is really important that some
people don't have when they do this and
start doing interviews it's just the
ability to just have a conversation with
the other person in a way where it's
just like a conversation and it seems
genuine and that is is huge and you know
like when you were on Joe Rogan I mean I
think one of the things he has is that
ability as well where you're just kind
of like you're observing a conversation
that real people are having which is
awesome so I encourage you to keep doing
it and by the way my producer is vegan
and he wanted me to ask you if you are
still vegan okay
nah man I'm not I I started to in 2012
that's when I started it and I didn't at
last but it's like six seven months I'm
extremely and I'm an advocate for a
plant-based lifestyle but yep for me it
was just - I don't want to have to think
about what I ate every single day you
have to plan everything cuz not every
restaurant has big an option it's not
every place you go has big in place so
it's just like it is I what if I died
earlier I'd die earlier and I know and
who know because you see Studies on both
sides of too much plant-based can do
this and too too much meat can do this
so it's like it's just you get lost in
the in the information so I just
everything in moderation is my is my my
my key now all right well he's gonna be
disappointed but I'll let him know I bet
[Laughter]
we end the show the same way every time
man when I started this I said I said a
real lofty goal and I said I want to
have Jim Carrey on my podcast so we've
asked everybody who's been on my podcast
to kind of advocate for Jim Carrey we've
had Snoop Dogg on we've had Auto great
we have a lot of great people on so
that's everybody from my mother
Snoop Dog's to say to try to get jim
carrey to advocate him to come on the
podcast man so if you could do the same
on how they'd appreciate it
why jim carrey I'm curious so Jim Carrey
is somebody who want to grew up loving
right - I think he is in a place in his
life right now where it is he says so
really outlandish [ __ ] and sometimes it
makes so much sense that I just want to
dig in you know it's like sometimes it
does it sometimes but it's yeah like I
have to know about this character man
and he says some and he said one of the
things that was really like it just
breathtaking to me we said well he said
we're all fields of energy dancing for
itself
it's poetically beautiful and like
scientifically accurate that's exactly
what's going on every single thing yeah
sometimes he makes a lot more sense than
Deepak Chopra so I've asked everybody to
get a more man to advocate for me man so
if you can do that I highly appreciate
cool yeah when the episode is out I will
tweet it and tweet it to him and say he
should appear on people look at the
camera and over like Jim so we're gonna
put together like a video marks oh you
want me to do it right now yeah all
right
Jim Carrey please do aryans show it's a
great show he's a great interviewer and
everybody wants to hear from you that's
good enough man I highly appreciate it
though well if anybody will flash sure
you're at so if anybody wants to find
you of anything you wanna promote man
you plug or whatever go ahead follow me
on Twitter deep Pakman and become a
subscriber on YouTube it's free it is
man and uh donate cuz that's I love the
content and and III appreciate the
[Music]